I'm so glad now that this is not a
boxing ring you know because I would
really lose this fight what do you think
when you hear about her doing three
matches there you did more didn't do
three matches yeah you see fighters
nowadays only need one or two bouts in
order to make millions of dollars when I
was fighting 4050 years ago I had to
fight 18 times in a year just to pay my
bills
so you know it was a different game then
than it is now
you know but a I congratulate you
and I saw you with your uppercut
dr. Carter please please take us back to
you were actually at the high point in
your career then oh yeah oh yeah in one
night in June you were you were arrested
well it did it really didn't happen in
one night in June you know I grew up in
a segregated society where people would
with my skin color wasn't allowed to eat
in restaurants wasn't allowed to go to
school I wasn't allowed to drink out of
water fountains and all that all that
kind of stuff so so I didn't grow up
passive I was very aggressive you know
when I grew up and and press the fact
that for the first 18 years of my life
on this earth I couldn't talk I
stuttered badly very very badly and
people laughed at me because of it you
know I didn't know you know that it was
hereditary my father studied you know
his father studied I didn't know that
nobody ever told me that so when people
laughed at me people made fun of me the
only sound that they hear in reply would
be the sound of my fists whistling
through the air you see so I was very
aggressive based upon that but I was
living in Paterson New Jersey at the
time I was perhaps the most celebrated
person
in that city at that time and I was
driving my car on the street Oh to 3
o'clock in the morning and I was stopped
by the police at a red light waiting for
the red light to change and the police
surrounding my car and told us to follow
the car to them and we were in a caravan
five police cars in my little white car
sandwiched in between them and they took
us to this barn grill Lafayette Bar and
Grill where there was 75 to 100 people
out in the street this is where we came
we became aware that something terrible
had taken place here and then they took
us to the hospital where one of the
surviving victims still survived and
they asked us just as you saw it in a
movie and the answer is are these the
people who did this and the man looked
at us and said no these are not two
people badly wounded big boy
the man was badly wounded oh he's shot
in the head and a bullet come out of his
eye that's badly wounded and in the
priests and are you sure this was not to
God because I've always had a very bad
relationship with the Patterson Police
Department anyway you know so they were
wanting to get me out of the way because
like as I said I talked you know what I
mean I was not passive how did you react
when you when you were put away like
that I was furious how would anybody
react I was absolutely furious I could
not believe this but you know what this
may seem ironic but going to prison
under the circumstances in which I went
to prison as a wrongly convicted person
was the best thing that ever happened to
me the best of very best thing because
without that I would have never stopped
long enough on my journey to know to
find out who I really am what I really
you were kind of different prisoner oh I
wasn't live I was never a prisoner that
was it he's in what sense because how
were locked away it made no difference
that they had me chained in shackled and
putting into a prison in a five by seven
foot cell just because a misinformed
jury fed on lies / you mean by jailhouse
snitches just because this misinformed
jury found me guilty did not make me
guilty you understand and when I went
into the prison I refused to act the
part of a guilty person I refused to
wear their clothes I refused to eat
their food I refused to work their job I
want to refuse to breathe the prison's
air if I could have done so and yet
remained a lot the one thing that I had
that could never be compromised was my
innocence
you understand so
solitary confinement what was that like
I spent close to 10 of the 20 years that
I spent in prison in solitary
confinement and solitary confinement
there was literally six feet under the
ground and total darkness no sanitary
conditions no running water no lights
five slices of stale bread to eat and a
cup of warm water to drink
but you were your own cult I wore much I
was sitting in solitary confinement for
a certain time I was free I was free I
was not gonna be a prison you don't say
myself until this suit became shredded
rags you know what I mean but I was
during all those years I mean you spent
2222 years for this yes right
did you ever sort of give up listen I
wanted to lay down a whole lot of time
but I couldn't I couldn't compromise my
innocence you know everybody said
whooping be like other prisoners be
ordinary so we can come down here and
visit you for 90 minutes once a month
you know you know it obey the rules and
it won't put you in solitary confinement
so even my family wanted me to give up
my protestations of innocence you know
so my family had to go to they had to
get away from you when I said that that
was the best experience that I ever had
in my life I simply mean that in prison
I learned the solution to dreaming the
solution to prayer and this is what
young people need to understand this
planet Earth is a paradise a fantasy
island whatever you can conceive in your
mind and believe
whatever it is can be achieved whatever
it is there are no limitations we live
in a universe of unlimited possibilities
and whatever you can conceive in your
mind and believe you can do it I mean my
sitting here and Stockholm Sweden with
you today is absolute proof of that
please welcome Holly Hunter